nous allons maintenant parler de r dans
l'express toujours qui sort demain sous
la plume de michel simon r la comédie
musicale de 69 décaper par
l'impertinence tchèque de milos forman
des caps et donc des poussières est pas
mal de choses alors qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce qu'on peut entendre par des cap et
par rapport à ce que vous aviez vu à sa
création
ça veut dire remise au goût du jour
moderniser
complètement transformé voulait
transformer complètement tend à
transformer l'histoire on n'a pas d'eau
rien pour changer des chansons musique
bien sûr mais mes devoirs a enregistré
naturellement on attend sûrement
beaucoup histoire est bon de café des
capes pour moi c'était une période
c'était un choc parce que je suis venu
en amérique pour la première fois privé
mans en 1967 68 alors c'était l'époque
des hippies d'assassinât de robert
kennedy de martin luther king
après on est on est je suis venu en
france pour trouver un peu de calme en
mai 68 mais quand vous avez vu air la
première fois vous avez eu envie de
monter déjà ce spectacle qui savaient
pas marcher vous n'avez pas pu le faire
vous j'ai vu la première présentation
publique off broadway en automne 67 et
j'ai oublié de faire tout de suite je
n'ai pas compris pas un mot mais la
musique m'a frappé vraiment c'était
tellement naïve de moi de ma part de
penser que nous donnerons des chansons
je fais quelque chose
bon alors bien entendu il faut préciser
que toute votre troupe à vous la troupe
du film est une troupe complètement
nouvelle avec dvd jeunes chanteurs
danseurs qu'on ne connaît pas encore en
europe vous n'avez garder personne de la
première de ce qui avait créé air aux
états unis on a on a fait on voit deux
de ses tonnages melba mourir leader
comment nos marchés toutes les autres
sont jean nouvel qui sont venus de
théâtre des groupes de rock par exemple
un garçon qui joue avec la gauche
chicago en garçons qui jouent que le
théâtre en matière qui joue dans les
prisons pour les prisonniers avaient
auditionné des milliers des centaines de
jeunes jardi siens plus que mille
personnes
parce que je voulais que
tout le monde qu'on voit sur l'écran
peut chanter les chansons on a pas on
n'a pas doublé d'une personne le
scénariste mais ce voleur et le
chorégraphe c'est tout la charge qui est
un très très grand chorégraphe 4 avec
baryshnikov l'american ballet mais il
n'avait pas l'expérience de ce genre de
spectacle
nantes mais que vaut leur toit la femme
moi même on a fait jamais des musicales
enfin la frappe ceux d'une personne très
difficile mais moi je les adore c'est
aujourd'hui peut-être la plus qu'avant
de guerre très mal et je n'avais pas eu
peur milos forman de voir qu'à une
certaine époque on a essayé de remonter
air sur scène et ça a été comme on dit
un beat de notre métier ça a été un
échec la reprise ça vous a pas empêché
de tenter l'aventuré ça me faisait grand
plaisir parce que ce n'était pas facile
parce que vous comprenez les auteurs ont
vécu avec chaque mo pour 10 ans alors
chaque - devenue un morceau de décor le
changer à mon cet homme coupé un doigt
alors cet échec les a fait un peu plus
modeste modeste de me laisser faire ce
que j'ai pensé le faire alors la
distribution va voir un extrait sait à
quoi on y est ce qu'on est dans un parc
très concentré très drôle
quels sont les rôles de ces demoiselles
j'en ai d'ailleurs la photo s'étalait
d'angelo ici dans l'express sont la voie
bondissante sur scène et puis treat
williams et eli gold jeanine l art et l
on voit un extrait on en parle après
[Musique]
il
comment
[Musique]
à gauche
bon
[Musique]
hu
des noms
[Musique]
je ne peux pas
m
oh
à
baa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
m
à
comment
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
[Musique]
ça me rappelle de bons souvenirs aux
japonais voix vous les avez trouvés ces
chevaux savant à ce sont des pick and go
alors on va reparler des rôles des trois
qui sont bons a révélé ben ali rapporte
dans le film la place parce que c'est
une fille d'une famille très très bon
jour à nouveau de lutte on veut chériaux
je rapporte la fierté et n y apporte la
tendresse la grand problème les
ensembles elle ne sait pas avec qui mais
elle saurait bientôt parce que si le
garçon c'est le bébé sera ce blanc on
sait que c'est un gars ont su conclure
en tout cas exalead elle se promène avec
une petite médaille avec l'air autour
découvrir c'est un peu comme ce que de
camaraderie de l'équipe parce que c'est
lui le chef électricien qu'il a donnée
est ce que vous avez eu du mal sûrement
pas d'ailleurs à convaincre les
producteurs à financer votre film sans
doute pas après le triomphe de du nid de
coucou dans le monde entier
non c'était pas de problème de
l'argent avait beaucoup de problèmes
avec le temps parce que commencer
tourner tout ça en octobre alors à
tourner encore en décembre en dehors de
danse
[Musique]